[Music]
welcome back to my filmmaking journey I
started this segment because I wanted to
have a way to communicate more with you
guys about my ideas my concepts things I
want to make things I want to do career
goals that I'm pursuing and I want to
use this episode to talk about how notes
from Melanie is doing it festivals talk
to you guys about some of the new
festivals that have accepted it so you
guys can know ahead of time if you want
to go see it and also talk about
something that I think is discussed but
maybe not enough and that is um what it
feels like to be rejected from a
festival and I also want to make sure
you stay tuned to the very end of the
episode because this is sponsored by
Skillshare and I'm gonna be talking
about them at the end of the video so
thank you so much to Skillshare for
sponsoring this video
so notes from Melanie our new short had
its premiere at the short sweet Film
Festival in Cleveland Ohio I went there
with my buddy John Flickinger who also
has a bit of a role in the film and we
had a great time it was encouraging and
inspiring to see so many people who had
come from far away to see the movie and
meet them and talk with them obviously I
was nervous because I had watched the
film so many times by myself or with
just friends or people who were
reviewing the film like to give me notes
and feedback so that I could try to make
it better and I had never really
experienced it with a big crowd before
and so as any filmmaker knows when you
first show your movie to a crowd it's
like it takes on a different life you
can see how other people are reacting to
it and you hope that they notice subtle
things and nuances that you tried to
incorporate into it and when they do
it's just so gratifying and you're like
yes okay cool you guys are feeling this
and you're understanding what I was
going for and it was just a wonderful
experience honestly to be there amongst
so many like-minded people who
appreciated movies and so many people
who talked to me about wanting to make
films as well and what they were going
for and who their inspirations were it
was just a great experience and so so
much fun it's a good time
I think it stole the whole show in my
opinion I think the lens flare agrees
with you that's happening right now this
is this vlog version by JJ Abrams good
yeah yeah that was fun that honestly was
a really really good time I met a lot of
really cool people like people I'm
losing my voice from talking so loud
actually but that was just kind of
inspiring you see it on the big screen
and like here people like enjoying it
and just like laughing along with the
funny parts and honestly that was just
really fun my heart was pulsating the
whole time it was and I was a little bit
I was like oh it's like surreal
you're seeing yourself as a big yellow
insect man it was a good feeling was
really fun it's perfect I think it went
as well as it possibly could have I
agree so for those who haven't had a
chance to see the film yet I am trying
to do my best to get it in as many
festivals as possible as most of you
know that means it's up to them to
accept it or not and some have rejected
it and some have accepted it we'll talk
about that soon but if you haven't seen
the film I can tell you some places it
has been accepted to that are coming up
very soon on April 20th the film is
gonna be shown at the Hollywood comedy
shorts festival now this is special for
a lot of reasons for one I got the movie
to California that was something I
really wanted to do and for - it's gonna
be shown at the TCL Chinese Theatre
the iconic theater on Hollywood
Boulevard and they project through DCP
which is the best way to project a film
in a theater as far as I'm concerned and
so I am just so happy that that's
happening April 20th if people are
around that area and you want to go see
it please do check it out get a ticket
support a tiny movie from Ohio from a
bunch of people who are just trying to
create something and I'm really happy
it's it's being there that's just that's
a dream come true to get a movie in that
theater that's just awesome on April
21st it's gonna be shown at the indie
film Wisconsin festival that's in
Watertown Wisconsin it's a small theater
it's a charming little festival - called
the town cinema it's their first year
and I'm excited that our film was gonna
be there so if you're in that area
that's a place you can see it on April
27th it's gonna show at the Canton Film
Festival here in Ohio I'll be there so
be nice to meet you if you guys are in
the area you can come and see it and on
May 9th it's gonna show at the
Philadelphia Independent Film Festival
so if you're in Philadelphia you get a
chance to see it it recently showed a
couple days ago at the Arizona
International Film Festival as well and
so I'm excited that it's going outside
of Ohio
now I've submitted to many other
festivals throughout the year but their
notification dates are spread out all
the way until like October and so
there's still gonna be a lot of places
that I don't know whether or not they
accept it or deny it and I will give you
guys updates either through a video like
this or on Twitter so you guys can
hopefully see it I have submitted to
places outside of the United States a
few of them have already denied it and
that's just it happens it's something to
be expected and I would like to talk
about that a little bit because when I'm
a daught aureum 6 I remember so many
festivals rejecting it and I remember
feeling just really disheartened by that
at first until I started talking to
other filmmakers good filmmakers like
people who were already established and
I was talking to them in private and
they were like oh my god yeah my films
were rejected all the time so how should
you react to your film getting rejected
from a festival how should you process
that as a filmmaker does that mean your
film isn't good enough does that mean
you didn't work hard enough maybe that's
possible it's possible that your film
just isn't good enough perhaps it's not
up to par technically perhaps the sound
wasn't as good as it could be or the
video presentation or maybe the film
just isn't really that good and the
festival didn't like it or the judges
didn't like it
sometimes the festival can be filled
with like multiple judges and maybe
three out of five liked your film and
those two who hated it it's just no
longer unanimous and because of those
two who hated it your films not gonna
get shown and that could happen too
there are so many variables but one of
the biggest reasons your film can get
rejected that sometimes isn't discussed
that much is that it just didn't fit in
line with the theme they were going for
sometimes a festival picks a theme for
the year maybe they just want to really
talk about a certain specific type of
film and they want to show those types
of movies they want to have a very
serious festival maybe they're very
documentary heavy it helps to do
research about the festival before you
submit to
because you might see that the films
they generally accept are serious dramas
or maybe there are more comedy based or
sci-fi horror based so doing research
about the type of film that's normally
shown there can really help you to
submit to a festival that might want to
show your film more so than others at
the same time a festival judge might
start choosing great films early on it's
always best to submit as early as
possible so that you can get in their
brains as quick as possible because if
you wait too long you're going to be
competing for spots that have already
been filled by films that have been
accepted way ahead of time at least in
their minds they've accepted these films
like these films have to be in our
festival you know they haven't set out
the acceptance letter yet but they know
they really want to show this film so
the earlier you submit the better but as
those judges watch those first few films
like early in the submissions process
and they start to pick out different
types of themes and they realize that
they are creating a feel for the
festival despite the fact that your film
might be really good they might just not
pick it because it doesn't fit in with
what they're building for their show in
the case of our film I'm glad that I did
a lot of research ahead of time like for
specific festivals and what I thought
they would like to see the films that
they normally are excited to show I also
targeted a lot of comedy based festivals
because the films are comedy and so you
have to be smart with the way you submit
but when a film is rejected it it's
always gonna hurt a little bit I mean I
open up the email and it says your
submission status has been updated and
you go to it you're like oh not accepted
okay
and the worst part is sometimes they
never write you they won't tell you why
you'll just get a little PNG image
sometimes the least a festival can do
though is tell you why your film wasn't
good enough some of them do some of them
won't you just have to deal with it and
I've had to learn to deal with that over
the past couple years and for some
festivals you can respectfully email
them and say thank you very much for
watching my film I am curious as to what
we could do to improve in the future do
you guys offer screener notes
and many times they will get back to you
quickly and respectfully and explain
exactly why your film wasn't accepted
and sometimes it is for the exact
reasons I just said sometimes it has
nothing to do with quality but I also
know filmmakers who are trying to get
out there who submitted to like 20
festivals and they all just denied it
and then your film just kind of sits
there and you resort to uploading it to
YouTube and hoping that somebody
stumbles across it and that happens
sometimes too and that's never a good
situation sometimes though that might be
because your film just wasn't good
enough and you just haven't learned
enough yet I know that for a fact
because I've dealt with that many times
I have made countless shitty short films
I mean tons it's impossible to make
something good right out of the gate you
can't you have to make you have got
to make so much
before you can even make something
remotely competent and in my case I know
that's true I spent tons of years as a
teenager just making amateur garbage
having fun with my friends and that's
fine you're supposed to do that and
sometimes people get overzealous and
sometimes you might want to release one
of those films to a festival and they're
just like look this isn't good enough
and then you have to really take that
process that and figure out how to be
better and I've had to do that for years
and I'm still doing that every time I
write something and I show it to either
an industry colleague or a friend
inevitably they will come back with
notes wow this is good wow this is
really cool wow that sucks dude
what the hell are you thinking and it's
just you need that you really need that
feedback and that's why it really does
suck when a festival just says your film
isn't accepted and they don't tell you
why because that you can't learn from
that you can't build from that there's
no way you can improve and so there have
been times where I've reached out to
festivals 80% of the time they've gotten
back to me with reasons and it's helped
a lot Cleveland International was a big
one for me that I really wanted to get
into because a I've wanted to support
Ohio film forever I'm trying to get more
films made here
by lobbying for a credit that can
increase Ohio's tax incentive for film
to a hundred million and I have features
that I want to shoot here that I'm
currently trying to finance which if it
works out there'll be another video
about that in the future can't really
talk about it right now but cool stuff
on the horizon that's what I'll say but
in the case of Cleveland International I
submitted the film on the last possible
day the last day for a deadline that's a
big issue immediately that's a big
problem of mine we had a lot of
post-production issues which I've talked
about before in other videos where we
were trying to scramble to complete
visual effects for certain sequences and
because of that we were pretty late so
that automatically makes it harder for
me to get in anyway because they've
probably already seen a lot of films
that they've accepted in their minds and
they know they want to put their also at
19 minutes were a little long for a
short and like the original cut was like
25 minutes and I cut cut cut cut cut I
mean I made it as quick as I possibly
could and they also didn't provide any
screener notes and that happens so how
do you deal with a situation like that
do you just say okay well I didn't get
into the one festival I really wanted to
get into I guess the film is I
guess it's not gonna be seen of course
not no you just move on you keep writing
you submit to other festivals and you
try again it's that easy it's that
easy my friends and I have been
talking a lot about this lately I have
two really great writer friends who we
get together and we we kind of pitch
ideas to each other and we try to come
up with things we'd like to do together
and we've all just decided that there's
nothing holding us back
it's so easy especially for creative
people to just defeat yourself
constantly in your mind you have ideas
you have talent you have ability or at
least you have the drive to learn or the
drive to succeed so what's stopping you
you know I always ask that of myself
constantly what in my life is a
roadblock to achieving my goals and I
try to figure out if there is an axe
we'll roadblock for real or if it's just
something I've created subconsciously
that doesn't even exist most of the time
it doesn't exist and it's just myself
humbling myself into the ground until I
don't feel like being creative anymore
I'd say it was about when I turned 30
that I just said screw this man this is
I'm done waiting you know I sometimes
listen to a podcast called the movie
crypt and they often ask their guests at
what point in time in their lives did
they realize that getting a film made
wasn't just gonna fall into their lap
and they had to basically dig and dig
and dig until they got something done
just out of pure sweat blood and tears
and I think for me it was around when I
turned 30 and I just realized I should
just work my ass off and that's one of
the biggest reasons you saw less reviews
last year because I've spent most of the
year just writing feature screenplays
and talking to people making phone calls
having meetings I've gotten farther
professionally than I ever have in my
life just in the past year purely from
Drive alone most of my writer friends
have told me the same thing let's say
you have a great script a great
screenplay and you think you could
probably get this funded and financed if
you just knew who to talk to that's
awesome you should have three though and
all of them told me the same thing I
wrote a script that most people seem to
like as I as they read it but I wrote
one script that most people seem to like
and they said dude you need to have at
least three my one friend wants at least
six before he starts pitching for real
like trying to get his movies made and
so having multiple scripts as well is a
great thing because let's say also the
blacklist people don't that sight to see
some of the best reviewed unproduced
scripts that are being tossed around the
industry and you can go to that site and
you can put one of your scripts on there
but the issue is let's say you wrote the
best script they've ever read
but it's kind of expensive and you've
never directed or you've never had a
film made before they're gonna call you
up and they're gonna say that's great
what else you got and if that's all
you've got that might be the end of the
conversation you
may have written the next inception but
since you've never made a movie before
they don't want to finance it you need
to have at least three you know other
conversations you can have with these
people who are interested in you
so that's kind of what I'm working on
right now the space I'm in is just
trying to build a catalog so that I can
then have that opportunity where if
someone does read something I write
likes it but doesn't want to finance
that exact script and they asked me what
else I have I can say here you go
tons of stuff check it out let me direct
something so I'm working pretty hard
right now to get things like that done
and I'm excited about notes from Melanie
being in festivals and I'm just I'm
happy to be sharing these things with
you guys and I hope that with this
segment I can not only talk about this
aspect of my life more and my career
goals but also and more importantly
reach some of you guys who are maybe in
a similar place trying to figure out
what you want to do career-wise with
your films or your scripts or whatever
it is you're working on and I hope that
in some way this segment can help and I
also want to give a big thank you to the
sponsor for this video and that is
Skillshare Skillshare is an incredible
online community with tons of classes
over 25,000 classes and things like
design and business there's writing and
film based things you can learn just
about anything there it's extremely
helpful for people who are trying to
figure out what they want to do in this
industry especially film there are so so
many helpful videos and classes and
tutorials about editing and creative
writing some of the ones that I
specifically liked where the writers
toolkit six steps to a successful
writing habit and creative writing
essentials writing standout opening
scenes I cannot tell you how important
the opening scene is for your script
especially if you've never had a film
made before if it's a spec script many
readers will toss your script in the
garbage if the first 10 pages don't hit
them that is the absolute truth it's
unfortunate but it's true and you can
find so many classes just like that that
can help you with those very things on
Skillshare the Premium Membership gives
you unlimited access so you can join the
classes and communities that are just
right for you whether you want to feel
your curiosity creativity or even career
skill share is the perfect place to keep
you learning and through
Skillshare is also super affordable at
less than $10 a month but the best part
is that if you use this link which is in
the description below
the first 500 of you can get a two month
free trial so please do visit that link
and check out Skillshare I really do
think it's a helpful tool for people who
are trying to break into the film
industry and even if that's not your
goal there's so much else on there that
you can learn from so guys thank you so
much for watching another episode of my
filmmaking journey and thank you to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video
I'll have more updates for you guys very
soon lots of things to come that I
really am excited to talk about thank
you guys as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you